welcome back to unfiltered michael
avenatti he's once the media poster boy
remember him he's going to take down
donald trump well he's already been
convicted on extortion charges by trying
to extort nike and just yesterday he was
found guilty on wire fraud and
aggravated identity theft charges from
his dealings with his former client
stormy daniels
joining me now our former federal
prosecutor francie hanks and michael
avenatti's defense attorney andrew dalek
andrew i'll go to you first listen
michael avenatti's image you know he
went from this on the left
anti-corruption attack dog whatever to a
convicted felon for attempted extortion
and now wire fraud you think his
politically charged appearances in the
media you know hurt him in his personal
legal battles here
thanks for having me on dan you know i i
can't really uh speak to that um that
that question in particular but you know
i i think the fact that uh mr avenatti
faced um you know three different
indictments
in two different districts
certainly suggests that you know there
was a concerted effort across two
different u.s attorney's offices to um
to go after him as aggressively as as
possible and you know it's it's it's
certainly you know possible that uh the
fact that he you know had such a high
profile made him um such a significant
you know target for them
uh francie you know the evidence that
juries these are two juries here i mean
you know they they were both agreed to
i'd assumed by both sides you know and
he was embraced by many on the left
even considered wanting for running for
president one point you know what's the
lesson the american public you know
should learn from this here i mean you
know you put your name out there if
you've got all this uh dirty laundry
behind you
yeah the lesson i think dan is beware
the charlatans
anyone with any sense should have known
from the moment avenatti hit the scene
that he was a charlatan the things that
he was was saying was outrageous not
just about president trump but most
specifically about judge brett kavanaugh
at the time now justice brett kavanaugh
when he represented julie swetnick
avenatti did and said that kavanaugh and
others had gang-raped
teenage girls in high school and yet
somehow no one had ever heard about this
it was an absurd story he was a
charlatan from the beginning and now we
know he's not just a charlatan he's a
criminal and he stole money from his
client stormy daniels while he was
telling her she wasn't getting paid he
was actually taking the money from her
yeah i mean i just think
if you've got all this uh you know you
got this stuff sitting there in your
closet you know it's there right it's
you
then why would you go out in front of
the media make yourself this big public
figure i mean he had all these
appearances in front of the media
knowing that this was going to open this
this closet door was going to open guys
ladies thanks a lot really appreciate
you are you taking the time hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else